what is happening there citizens the
reject Nation we are here to continue
the what season is it again oh my God
yeah I've lost track we're gonna
continue season four Brooklyn nine nine
today what we ask of you guys to help
get this video some eyes is leave a like
that does help out the video so please
if you have been watching us leave a
like it goes a long way also uh
full-length of action watch long story
single with your own copy of Brooklyn
Nine-Nine available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page come become
a sexy reject today to see all the
things that we cover exclusively with
reaction highlights watch alongs
included John excited to return very
excited sir how are you are you excited
I'm excited let's get to it
[Music]
two months ago Gina linetti was hit by a
bus and the brightest star in the cosmos
was extinguished his 10 pages I can't
read it his doctor said it was okay for
her to come back to work today here she
is
how long do you have to wear the the
metal called a halo for another week
drilled into my skull here I can still
hear the screws squeaking into the bones
oh my God I always wanted to get hit by
a bus yeah I mean I was legally dead for
two full minutes and I met God tight
what does she look like ethnically
ambiguous
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
dead for two minutes that's crazy
solid cold open people
crime in Brooklyn is down significantly
they'll be permanently Closing one
Precinct an auditor will arrive shortly
there are 22 other precincts in Brooklyn
so we just don't want to rate at the
bottom are they going to be looking at
our desks also unrelated someone left a
bunch of swords on my desk
the auditor will start by joining
Peralta and Santiago on their gang
Stakeout because they are America's
dream couple your case is a good example
of the type of serious crime that still
exists the auditor is here isn't that
Teddy imy's ex-boyfriend yes good Amy
didn't you tell him to his face he was
the most boring man alive Yep this is
gonna be awkward we had a good run let's
not panic Jake Amy nice to see you teddy
nice to see you too I just hope I don't
bore you yeah what's that the crime
phone is ringing phone
he is boring his favorite app on his
phone is contacts oh I don't think our
relationship can survive that I mean
even if we don't work together we can
still be a couple if I don't see you
every day I will forget who you are I'm
like a goldfish
maybe you have ADD yes that is
approximately 50 feet by 40 feet
actually 52 feet by 41 feet I'll just
look at the blueprints at the city
planner's office fun I assure you you'll
find zero waste here really because I
did notice you recently purchased a 21
000 copy machine wow that machine saves
money in terms of man hours we need to
go to the BRB or BRB
this closet is for people who are
freaking out oh I'm fully freaking out I
just experimented with an unfamiliar
acronym BRB what does it even mean be
right back it is the same number of
syllables as the acronym
good point yeah
foreign
for having roaches so what we don't have
roaches our rats ate all of them no damn
it
get some cats who forget how I am he's
like a goldfish this is all your fault
you just had to sleep with Teddy didn't
you you couldn't keep it in your pants
your libido has endangered us all
wait Tina you should you can fit in
because of my injury I can no longer fit
in well I meant physically I am
physically as strong as I've ever been I
can do anything okay and I'll be an
ableist Terry this is too crowded I
shouldn't have wasted my speech on this
moment
we just have to pretend that he's
interesting I got pretty good at it
while we were dating we just have to
smile and Nod and agree with whatever he
said last oh no probably Jeremy Irons
but maybe it's Timothy Oliphant or it
could be William Atherton definitely the
last one right William Sadler pilsners
he loves talking about pilsners oh my
God just saying the word gives me PTSD
Phil's new TSD good one oh they're cute
and make Teddy feel like he's the most
interesting man on Earth go there and
make him I feel like whoever that person
is let's go I know that New Yorker
reference I've read his stuff
I have recently come into a lot of wolf
urine it creates a scent impression that
there are predators nearby I've been
dousing nikolaja's shoes with it to
scarif boys at his preschool did it work
no he's much worse off oh buddy we can
use it to hurt them towards traps what
about me like what should I do I just
thought maybe you could take it easy
it's your first day oh I am as strong
physically as I have ever been yeah I
have short-term Amnesia I got hit by a
bus
[Laughter]
Teddy how's it going my man nice to see
you I'm glad we get to spend this time
together who could say when people last
saw people
we think they're meeting up with leaders
of another gang to possibly merge
organizations detectives demonstrate a
passable knowledge of their operations
so hey we might be here for a while can
I offer you a beverage Dos Equis for The
Most Interesting Man actually I
shouldn't it'll make me all hyper suit
yourself too bad we're on the job right
could have stocked that thing with
pilsners you like pilsners and kills for
the pills my total pills nerd I'm using
that
what's your uh poison German or Bohemian
the last one that you said good choice
the last one always is wow this is fun I
can talk with you he's got to be on to
this
just caught detectives s p in a bald
face line oh God you know like prisoners
you hate prisoners you think they're
boring and you still think I'm boring No
Lie detectives s p did lie to Texas SNP
no
[Laughter]
no
the screen just shows a cartoon turtle
sobbing and what about when the little
sushi roll comes out and cuts the
Turtles out toner issue toner issue of
course
laughs
hey Captain I'm glad you're here to see
this I'm just about to drink my tea
Terry
oh
it's like the mech suit from Avatar 2.
are you dress like that Mobility it's a
good thing I still have my sexy cat
costume from Halloween I really don't
think you were the target audience for
that item there's nothing gendered about
a sexy cat please tell me that big jug
of wolf pee I rub on my kid
over here we're going together I was
boring it took our breakup for me to
realize that I found my Wild Side my
girlfriend and I do 5Ks now we took a
two-week trip to San Diego last year the
energy of that place is electric
[ __ ] I hope I don't bore you to
death
that was a joke humor is the tool of the
interesting
yeah the lady turned me on to something
called adult coloring books which we do
ask
Jazz brunches what brunch is crazy
enough on its own then you throw jazz in
the mix it's like why are we even doing
this oh no now they're the boring ones
reminder we're in good but I am actually
going to email you the invite if you
could just RSVP to that I feel better if
everyone had it on their calendars we
all have calendars so that'll work out
great because we all have one you know
Amy does update on the rat situation
wolf peas in place and The Traps are set
in the evidence room I thought we were
luring them into the break room Gina
needed for meditation
strong you will have your revenge on all
New York city buses
the last thing we need is a flood I'm
sure you'll have me down in no time
incorrect that would make a hole in the
ceiling you're there till Monday we'll
bring you some food in a bucket sure
oh God when I get back remind me to tell
you all about the omnibar station we
will spoiler alert two kinds of bell
pepper
perhaps
that's him trying to be interesting that
is spring break Teddy how did you ever
date him are they still recording
perfect timing successful Stakeout
there's no way that Sergeant boring big
winner will shut us down now get an
answer got the old phonester I'd like to
go through my contacts while I go pee
say all I need is one hand that's great
no look they're still recording still
yeah yeah exactly
oh this is bad what what's wrong
oh my God I was recording the whole time
we said all that bad stuff but while I
have you just stop me
daddy split she's doing Jazz about
brunch we could start a new life in the
country maybe open a small bookstore
dare you tap me with a small bookstore
we need to focus oh oh it would be so
lovely stage a fake fight this will be
fun right pretending like we have things
to be mad at each other about Jake's
chronic tardiness fact that he wasted
half the morning deciding what sneakers
to wear those are just some of the
reasons we're late
how did you guys meet
such a wild story so I was on an
elevator and so is Teddy
oh I think it's romantic I remember when
our relationship had magic moments like
that before it went stale you want some
action Jackson well how about I make a c
slip at a tablets it's bolted down oh
what a shock you tried something and
failed okay you know what that's it
oh my god oh no keep your eyes on me as
I make this sincere apology I am sorry
it's okay something crazy always happens
at jazz brunch it's the wild west Teddy
look what happened your phone landed
directly in this class of objects
Terry crushed it yes I've never been
more proud of you for anything in your
life I've solved a lot of cases for you
and yet crime is continuing
where are the rats there's blood
everywhere this is a horse oh no
it's from a closed case in 1986 when
they busted the guy that dealt to the
New York Mets my God those rats have
eaten the purest cocaine in the history
of this city they know and look
back in the walls
walls
oh no
well be careful of the ceiling submit to
them
Charles Thomas
that was fun totally I just said all
that stuff to save the precinct and
that's all you don't actually care about
my sneakers no
[Music]
not a good time we're still having a
pretty big fight well I think what I'm
about to say myself things Amy I'm still
in love with you what what what oh this
is super uncomfortable
okay okay everybody just calm down and
take a deep breath
friend I know I know and she's fine oh
ouch
will you marry me what Teddy I don't
want to be with you you guys have
nothing in common oh yeah tell that to
William Atherton the man we both
considered to be the second best Die
Hard villain she meant it oh
I love that Jake's a little messy and
that he cares so much about his dumb
sneakers and he doesn't get stressed out
about calendars I have to tell you the
truth Amy is dying she has one month to
live marrying her would be a waste of
time
Scout and you were in the
bed said you were the most boring man in
America in your phone recording you to
get mad at us and
you guys are the worst you just proposed
in front of your girlfriend so potato
potato Amy I loved you I talked to NYPD
facilities to see if they could get an
emergency Cleanup Crew out
the rat's only got into the cocaine
because you put the traps in the
evidence room we were going to use the
break room but Gina was in there and she
got hit by a damn bus so nobody can say
no to her nobody can say no to her hey
answer still no right but maybe you
should speak to my colleague first hi
I got hit by a bus
how'd it go with Sergeant Wells let's
see he proposed to Amy she said no and
then his girlfriend dumped him Terry's
getting nervous it's worse than it
sounds there is a jazz Branch involved
oh my God
that Sergeant Wells handles this like a
professional and respects the uniform
that we all wear sure
yes we're hoping that you'll give us a
fair evaluation I will not I'm recusing
myself oh that is so sweet thank you for
being such a good guy Teddy okay Amy
Santiago will you know oh God
our Precinct is immaculate I'm sure that
your new auditor Lieutenant Hopkins will
be very impressed Veronica Hopkins
that's the one the good news is
everything has not dated her I don't
know but someone has yeah why can't any
of you keep it in your pants hello nine
nine I'm Lieutenant Hopkins come here
and give an old friend a hug hey so good
to see you
oh this place is fantastic this is
[Laughter]
oh God she seems nice not a doctor
she's a little sad feeling that comes
into my heart whenever the credits start
to play I know like it's ending it's
preparing for us to say bye to the
episode too soon but that was really
funny that was hilarious Gina's come
back I mean we I think we said uh it's
been a while I think we did say that
they would probably just resolve it
right away yeah and they did but they
made it really fun yes and it was a
solid through a lot a lot of great
physical bits I thought that was
probably the funniest she's ever been I
thought I thought that was just a
hilarious use of her injury
much like real life I think it's really
funny when people are injured and you
can poke fun at them so it's always a
great physical but it's easy setup
they're an easy target might as well
take advantage and Great Escape uh you
know shoots for you know sticky
situations thousand percent uh that was
I thought the escalation of all the bits
was really well done I love how it all
came like literally collapsing at the
end with the photocopy machine and the
rats like all in that one room it was
hilariously executed and uh this was
also Teddy's best episode he was so
funny yeah yeah it was great everyone
was so funny and what an interesting
what being called boring or annoying
might be the worst insults to some
people and like I would I would take big
insult to that that's why I only
returning comments so yeah I think that
they uh absolutely killed this episode
it was a really great return and uh
everyone was just accelerating
at the highest comedic level you can ask
for I have an episode of Brooklyn nine
nine true that dude they killed it they
murdered it they bludgeoned it to death
and put it in the ground like this
episode quite a bit as well uh almost
there's room for Teddy but you know I
appreciate that they they let him go off
in a row because I feel like some people
out there be like no he actually did get
kind of interesting only to then sort of
let you come back to the realization of
like oh no Jazz Brunch probably not
because that's the problem is I heard
jazz brunch and I was like sounds like
fun Jazz Brunch sounds like fun I don't
know okay I even thought Hol might be
into that I'm glad it's not me yeah yeah
to have them both be like like I'm so
sorry like like my condolences at the
end of the year yeah that sounds like
it'd be a fun time brunch and Jazz
what's bad about that yeah maybe they
can just sing about different things but
I feel like jazz brunch could be a
really interesting subject yeah Jazz
seems like the right kind of music to
digest to and I thought they were gonna
make him superintend like 5k Miles and
stuff like that there's an awful lot of
really fun things yeah so I thought they
were going to make the route of like
he's really interesting but funny enough
by making him deteriorate to that point
where he just lost all control of his
emotions
made him is significantly more
interesting yeah and I like that they
didn't betray I like that he never
became Petty like the whole time you're
worried he's gonna be Petty and they
keep not making that choice and he keeps
being just like so sincere and and
genuine and and just with no ill will
that you can't help but feel he's like
such a a delightful Sad Sack anyway yeah
because he seems like kind of a sad dude
but at the same time he's got all these
boring things that make him happy so
really how sad could he be
and I also did like the cute wrap around
when they're using real life issues they
have with each other Amy and Peralta to
Stage a fake out when there's sincerity
there but then to come out and go but
that's also what you appreciate about
each other it's like a lot of real
couples you know some of the things that
might annoy us are actually part of the
reasons why we might love each other so
it was a nice sweet sentiment at the end
yeah absolutely everything was firing on
all cylinders and I'm excited for the
setup that they had for the next episode
as well true that hopefully they keep
Gina in traction All Season All Season
don't have her heel
in real time they run out some great
bits from that sure that was
surprisingly funny I thought they were
doing a cop-out but it was actually
really funny alrighty guys well what did
you think about this episode of Brooklyn
nine nine make sure to leave a like
subscribe Also let's send this to the
patreon
Mikhail Lyndon Mikhail look the odds of
us going to Sweden
um pretty Slimmer at this moment but
I'll tell you if you got hit by a bus
and if you survived that bus hit
we would be there
maybe within like two months would take
a bus we'd take a bus
and we'd show up with the same bus yes
that you got hit by yeah at the hospital
we'll hail it and like ride it on a
ferry across the Atlantic Ocean to you
because we want to make sure that's all
we really know about you is like Sweden
and James Bond we need to make you even
more interesting so how would we make
you more interesting
we do emotionally scar you yeah trigger
you we'd want to see what it's like we
you're already suffering a physical
injury and most people don't survive
such a thing but then to bring the exact
bus your attacker
who the hospital where you should be
healing oh come on the emotional
reactions you could get would be
hysterical imagine the combination as
our smiling faces greet you on the death
machine to try to take you out pointing
and laughing at you and when you're
finally ready to be let go what do we do
we hit you again yes should have seen
that coming that one's your fault we're
gonna strike you down you knew we were
gonna do that but it's all for humorous
purposes to have a good laugh we'll get
it on camera and post it on tick tock
just messing with you buddy you're
already interesting enough if you watch
the episode you would get the shout out
but if you only skip to the shout out
you might think we're just being
insulting but it dealt with a character
who that people thought was boring and
the person getting hit by a bus so we
were just combining it
it wasn't actually about you I want you
to think it's I feel like it's um
see what I did I've included it all
you're so good I've included the whole
show and then now while you're sleeping
we'll have you get eat by rats in a cat
suit happy 2023 buddy
[Music]